Good morning, John, and merry Christmas!
So in the last few years, I couldn't help
but notice that in the lead-up to Christmas
there is this very strong desire among some
people to try and define exactly what Christmas
is, and then complain that it isn't being
done right.
We're focusing too much on consumption, on
the worship of the acquisition of material
things, we're not considering the religious
importance of the holiday, we're not focusing
on the historical roots of the holiday, and
all of these traditions are co-opted from
cultures that we kind of helped destroy.
Santa is a weird omniscient magical demi-god
that clearly anagrams to Satan, and the madness
of Christmas Eve consumerism is indicative
of everything wrong with Western culture.
Here's what I think about all this.
Culture is like light: it's all around us,
it makes our lives possible, it shows us where
to go, it defines how we see things, and it
helps us not stub our toes on weird institutions,
like the fact that you shouldn't feed ramen
noodles to your parents when they come visit,
and women can wear skirts but men have to
put each individual leg into a separate leg
prison, but you can't actually see light.
You can only see what light hits.
In the same way, even though culture informs
every bit of our lives, it's really difficult
to see.
Holidays and rites of passage are lenses that
focus that cultural light into forms that
we can actually see and hold and understand
and critique, and since Christmas, or more
broadly like, the holiday giving season, is
our culture's biggest holiday.
It is a time when our culture is very visible,
and so too are all of the bits of our culture
that don't quite jive with our worldview.
But unlike a lens that just focuses the light,
holidays actually give us an opportunity to
change the nature of the light, change the
nature of culture.
It's an opportunity to look at what our society
is made of, and maybe say, I don't want that
bit.
We can give charitable contributions instead
of gifts, we can focus on the happy wonder
of children or the Solstice or Jesus or whatever
tradition feels deepest and richest to you,
while doing our very best not to whine about
the fact that other people are doing it differently,
because the things that they value and the
culture that they live in is different from
ours, because they're different people.
For me this time of year, it's friends, it's
video games, it's Christmas trees, it's Ella
Fitzgerald, it's Buddy the Elf's breathless
enthusiasm infecting the whole world, it's
cats on Christmas trees.
This holiday season, whatever you want to
call it, has a really deep and diverse group
of traditions to draw on, because our culture
is made up of a really deep and diverse group
of people, and in the end, what shines through
all of these traditions is giving.
Wanting to make the lives of other people
richer and better so that they know that we
care about them, and that's a bit of our culture
that I have a hard time having a problem with.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.